foreign
you know I'm told that one of the most
popular things on the old internet for
the kids uh are the unboxing videos
where someone takes a box and opens it
and pulls stuff out of it it's riveting
content and so we're gonna do something
similar but uh the difference is that in
this case we are unboxing our own
merchandise because it's always about
selling stuff because we're greedy
capitalist pigs you know over the daily
wire store we've got all of our items
that you know about but we also have
these fan bundles just in time for the
holidays and so we're gonna unbox one of
the Matt wall show fan bundles and this
box you can get for only
250 dollars it's not what is it actually
it's not 250. is it 100 100 it's
actually a hundred dollars yeah I went
high so that when you heard the real
number it sounded lower in comparison
it's well worth a hundred dollars and
we'll uh we'll show why because we're
gonna go through I actually have not
been through this box yet so we will
experience this together and we start
with of course the classic the uh which
I I think is maybe the best item in any
store on The Daily wire is the walrus
plushie and also by the way I just want
to mention that we have a Johnny walrus
bundle if you don't want the whole box
you get the Johnny The Walrus bundle
including a book and a plushie and
that's just 34.99 for sale in the matte
wall store as well I brought a couple of
these home for my kids a few days ago of
course the problem has my wife pointed
out when I came home is that I brought a
couple of them home but I have more than
a couple kids and so it did start a
fight but uh that's fine you know I just
I believe in like you just take the toy
you throw it out to the kids let the
strongest man win and that's what we did
and of course we got the pronouns he him
wall Rooks as well so we've got that
that pairs nicely with Johnny The Walrus
uh which is of course my children's book
best-selling lgbtq plus children's book
well yeah I could easily say the most
influential lauded
celebrated award-winning lgbtq plus
children's book of all time if you
haven't read the book yet then now's a
perfect time to do so and this is good
for the kids it's also good for an
evening of reading just as an adult you
sit down with a glass of wine and you
curl up by the fire and read Johnny The
Walrus curl up with your pet walrus
stuff walrus as well what else we got
here well we've got our Patches from the
patch program if you think you're a
member of the sweet baby gang but you
haven't gotten your patches then you're
not a real member that's a rule that we
just I just decided we're putting in
place you have to have every patch in
our patch program to show your unabiding
fealty for the sweet baby gangs we got
all the patches we have our what is a
woman's circular definition sticker this
one I enjoy I have this one on my laptop
that uh during the show you can see and
I also that's like my actual laptops
this is a true story I was at in airport
bar a couple weeks ago and I was working
on my laptop at the bar as one does and
um the bartender saw the sticker and was
confused by it because she had no idea
who I was and never heard of the film
somehow she had never heard of what is a
woman try not to judge her for that and
she asked me what the sticker was from I
said oh it's from a movie that I made
and she asked me about the movie and I
said well it's a movie where I go around
asking what a woman is and she looked at
me awkwardly and backed slowly away and
then pairing with that even if you've
seen the film uh it's still worth
reading the book because there's a lot
of information in the book that we
couldn't get into the film in a 90
minute film so you learn a lot there and
then we've got our stickers of course
just the cloud you got to have the Matt
wall show and then the sweet baby gang
sticker both of those this is just this
is actually I think this is too much we
shouldn't be giving all this away for a
hundred dollars we should change the
price on this actually probably reshoot
this whole video
because each of these items is like this
this definitely the the total of item
value is like 300. hey we also have um
what is this a magnet I guess with the
should I exist Panda which is great and
you know one of the one of the themes
that you see in a lot of these items is
just confusion not that you're confused
but that you are making other people
confused when they see this so if
someone is not affiliated with or
familiar with the sweet baby gang and
they see this
magnet on your on your refrigerator with
a panda that says should I exist they're
going to be so confused which is great
and it gives you a chance this is a an
opportunity for evangelism it gives you
a chance to explain to them why pandas
are pathetic sons of [ __ ] and should
all die and then if the walrus plushie
is the best item across all stores then
the second best item is the chef self
apron as we get into the holidays you're
making meals for the family you want to
make sure that they respect your
pronouns which is so important and so
you got to get that apron so this is
great good this is I think this is uh
this is impressive all of these items
serve a purpose in the home and if
you're a true member of the Supreme gang
or even if you're not maybe you're
thinking yourself I'm not a member of
the sweet baby gang should I be but what
I would recommend is spend a hundred
dollars on sweet baby gang merchandise
see how it feels try it on and I think
you're gonna find that you want to be a
member or at least you'll say I've
already spent the money I might as well
and we'll take that too so head over to
dailywire.com shop
and get your bundle
[Music]